c'est quand de réfugié en Grèce et en
Turquie et l'accueil qui est fait à ces
milliers de personnes dans notre pays
alors après l'accord en mars dernier
entre l'Union européenne et la Turquie
sur cette crise des réfugiés le Sénat a
lancé une mission d'information sur la
position de la France à l'égard de cet
accord la commission des Affaires
étrangères a éitionné des chercheurs
autour de ce sujet l'analyse des flux
l'analyse des capacités d'accueil la
manière dont l'Europe gère cette crise
la remise en cause du Pacte des valeurs
européennes autant de thèmes qui vont
être abordés dans cette audition que je
vous propose d'écouter tout de suite on
a naturellement la question européenne
et de voir comment l'Europe gère et
finalement ce qu'on ne peut pas appeler
un accord mais plutôt une
transaction ceci avec beaucoup de de
difficultés qui vont peut-être même
jusqu'à une certaine forme de remise en
cause un peu du PACT de valeur
européenne tout ceci étant
particulièrement grave la réaction de de
l'Europe et puis naturellement aussi
toutes les questions qui sont liées au
fond des choses et donc à la situation
dans les pays sources et notamment les
aides au développement et les
perspectives d'évolution de ces pays
sources tout ceci nous pose en effet
donc de nombreuses questions sur lequel
ce que je vous propose c'est de faire
une intervention liminaire chacun
d'entre vous et puis ensuite que vous
puissiez répondre aux questions des
membres de la commiss
et donc je vais vous passer tout de
suite la parole dans dans quel ordre
Monsieur le Recteur d'abordordre
alphabétique alors allons-y c'est à vous
merci beaucoup voilà monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs merci d'abord de votre accueil
et de votre
écoute la situation en fait est assez
grave puisque c'est l'avenir de l'Union
européenne qui est en cause donc vous me
permettrez de tenir des propos qui ne
seront pas très adouci et pour cela je
voudrais euh répondre à trois points
premier point quelle est la nature de
cette migration sachant que je me
concentrerai sur ce que j'appelle les
migrants venus de Mésopotamie
c'est-à-dire de Syrie et d'Irak
deuxièmement l'analyse de la réaction
des pays européens comme l'a souhaité
monsieur le Président et troisièmement
je dirais quelle politique étrangère euh
pour les futurs
mois sur le premier point la nature de
cette migration est assez spécifique
c'est-à-dire que dans un premier regard
on pourrait penser qu'il s'agit d'une
migration classique cert intense mais
qui est lié à un conflit civil et nous
savons bien dans l'histoire que chaque
fois qu'il y a une guerre civile nous
avons des populations qui pour assurer
leur survie quittent leur territoire et
vont jusque au premier territoire où
elles peuvent se trouver en
sécurité ce qui peut paraître également
classique c'est que l'exode se prolonge
au fil des années tout simplement parce
que le conflit
perdure dans les territoires d'origine
c'est ce qui se passe toujours comme
dans la guerre de l'exyugoslavie où les
exodes n'ont cessé qu'après les accords
de d'ton et en même temps ce qui est
classique c'est la dimension
réémigration c'est-à-dire que lorsque
les possibilités de revenir sont faibles
et que le premier pays de refuge n'offre
pas des conditions satisfaisantes et
bien on cherche ailleurs une solution
plus satisfaisante et pourtant cet exode
il est tout à fait spécifique il est
spécifique en raison d'abord de la
nature plurielle des combats alors que
dans beaucoup de guerres civiles nous
n'avons que deux partis qui s'affrontent
en raison aussi de l'intrusion d'un
pouvoir géopolitique dénué de scrupulle
je parle de l'organisation état
islamique en raison du jeu trouble de
certaines puissances régionales et puis
également en raison du fait que c'est un
exode qui est pris dans un tourbillon
géopolitique puisque nous avons à la
fois des violences locales des
implication régionale et des acteurs
au-delà du Moyen-Orient qui
interviennent dans
ce conflit donc mon analyse c'est que
cette migration a des traits qui
conduisent à la définir comme sans
précédent historique face à cette
situation et j'en arrive à mon deuxième
point quel réaction des pays européens
et de l'Union européenne il est
essentiel de préciser que au départ de
cette crise qui commence comme vous le
savez en 2011 l'Union européenne
croit que se produit en Syrie une
révolution et non pas le début d'une
guerre civile et ce diagnostic est une
erreur absolument fondamentale dans la
mesure où il est lié à une
méconnaissance de la réalité
géopolitique tant interne de la Syrie
que de celle de l'ensemble du
Moyen-Orient et on le sait bien puisque
les représentants de la France quittant
ambassade de Damas en 2012 considère
qu'il vont revenir 15 jours plus tard
avec un nouveau régime qui sera au
pouvoir nous connaissons tous la suite
compte tenu de cette erreur d'analyse et
bien les pays européens et l'Union
européenne ont laissé faire c'est-à-dire
ne sont pas venus en aide comme il
aurait fallu le faire dès 2011 auprès
des pays de premier refuge et donc
l'Union européenne n'a pas développé de
Solid solidarité avec la Jordanie le
Liban et la Turquie dès le début du
conflit l'autre élément de qui est la
suite du fait d'avoir cru à une
révolution c'est l'oubli de l'importance
de la réémigration toute l'histoire
montre effectivement que des conflits
qui perdurent des situations qui ne sont
pas satisfaisante entraîne de la part
des personnes un souci de réémigration
et en enfin la non prise en compte comme
l'a dit le directeur de Frontex que la
Turquie s'est organisé à un moment donné
pour être une autoroute à migrant je
mets les mots entre guillemets puisque
ce sont ceux du directeur de Frontex ce
qui a facilité la vie des passeurs dont
je vous rappelle qu'ils ont eu un
chiffre d'affaires d'environ 10
milliards d'euros pour la seule année
2015 2è élément l'Union européenne
oublier l'importance de ces
omissions en matière de contrôle
frontralier en réalité le code frontière
Schengen n'est pas respecté non depuis
2011 mais déjà depuis
1987 simplement on s'en est rendu compte
contte tenu de l'importance de laaffu de
2015 mais il faut bien insister sur le
fait que le véritable problème c'est que
Schengen n'a jamais été appliqué
dès le début de sa mise en place et
c'est ce qui fait sa fragilité 3ème
élément le plan de répartition
ou de relocalisation de 160000 immigrés
sur cette question vous savez que dès le
début j'ai considéré que ce plan ne
serait pas appliqué pour une raison bien
simple parce que c'est un plan qui
considère des hommes comme des
marchandise et qui pense qu'on peut
assigner à résidence dans tel ou tel
pays de l'Union européenne selon une
pure répartition
géographique des immigrants qui ont
leurs propres objectif leurs propres
soucis en fonction des réseaux dont il
bénéficie ou des atouts qu'ils ont dans
tel ou tel pays de l'Union européenne
enfin 4è élément l'accord avec la
Turquie là aussi pour bien le comprendre
il faut évacuer les deux termes qui ont
été le plus employé dans les médias
d'abord l'idée que le président turc
faisait du chantage non il ne fait pas
du chantage il fait de la géopolitique
c'est-à-dire qu'il cherche à faire en
sorte que le rapport de force lui soit
favorable et lui permettre d'être dans
une situation plus agréable pour lui
bien sûr deuxème élément on dit c'est un
jeu de dupe non ce n'est pas un jeu de
dupe un jeu de dupe c'est quand on
trompe une personne sans qu'elle estit
le moindre soupçon dans cet accord il
suffit de le lire pour voir qu'il est
très facile pour les deux parties
d'avoir des soupçons euh sur euh les
conditions euh de cet accord donc face à
cette situation à la fois cette
migration sans précédent historique et
la réaction jusqu'à présent des pays
européens de l'Union européenne euh
quelle euh politique extérieure et ce
sera donc mon 3e et dernier point et
j'évoquerai donc quatre éléments premier
élément et bien c'est la nécessité de
faire un diagnostic
géopolitique suppos an de lutter contre
les causes de l'Exode parce qu'il faut
toujours rappeler que s'il y a
immigration c'est-à-dire arrivée de
personnes dans un pays c'est qu'il y a
d'abord immigration c'est-à-dire départ
des personnes d'un pays et donc c'est
bien ce départ qu'il convient d'agir et
pour agir sur ce départ il me semble que
la diplomatie suppose de pouvoir
discuter autant que possible avec
l'ensemble des partis
donc à partir du moment où les pays
européens ou l'Union européenne au lieu
de définir sa propre politique
extérieure sa ligne plutôt sur
Washington en ce moment peut-être à
d'autres moments sur Moscou elle n'a
plus le voix au chapitre et c'est bien
ce qui se passe en ce moment dans
l'ensemble de ce conflit donc ce
diagnostic est tout à fait essentiel
c'est il il aura inévitablement
conclusion la nécessité de développer de
véritables actions géopolitiques et pas
de se contenter de bons sentiments qui
conduisent d'ailleurs aux catastrophes
que nous constatons deuxièmement il est
très important là où la sécurité est
assurée dans les territoires de
Mésopotamie d'aider les personnes à
vivre au pays et donc en fait de
d'éviter qu'elles aient envie de partir
et à cet égard il faut rappeler le drame
qui a été la mort d' LAN Kurdi sur une
plage de Turquie en effet la famille de
ce petit garçon venait de cobané
c'est-à-dire d'une ville
libérée cette ville était libérée mais
nous n'avons pas bougé le petit doigt
pour sa reconstruction alors que
heureusement chaque fois qu'il y ait une
catastrophe naturelle dans un pays du
monde nous essayons de l'aider à s'en
sortir donc c'est
bien que la ville soit libérée la
famille de ce garçon est n'espér pas
dans l'amélioration de sa situation donc
nous devons là où la sécurité correcte
aider les personnes à vivre au pays
voire à y retourner ce qui passe par une
aide à la reconstruction ce qui passe
par la livraison de médicaments et
cetera 3ème élément et bien Schengen
n'étant plus
appliqué il faut le réinventer sachant
qu'il est essentiel de bien comprendre
que Schengen ne peut fonctionner que si
l'on respecte les deux pH que Schengen
représente c'est-à-dire que la liberté
de circulation à l'intérieur de Schengen
suppose inévitablement un contrôle j'ai
pas dit une fermeture je parle un
contrôle aux frontières extérieures et
donc soit il est doit être décidé
d'appliquer le code frontière Schengen
soit il doit être décidé de mettre en
œuvre d'autres modalités de respect de
Schengen sinon Schengen ne pourra pas
perdurer enfin 4è point et bien il
s'agit donc d'organiser la réémigration
de telle façon que l'on ne permet plus
aux passeurs de profiter de la pauvreté
des migrants cela signifie par exemple
que les hot spots qu'il a été décidé
d'installer en Grèce ne devrait pas être
en Grèce mais il devrait être en
Jordanie au Liban ou en Turquie donc
dans les pays de premier refuge puisque
toutes tous les migrants qui arrivent
dans les hospos de Grèce ont déjà
financé les passeurs et en même temps
nous voyons bien le rôle de la Turquie
puisque si depuis les accords avec la
Turquie il y a une
diminution du passage en mgé cela prouve
en même temps que la Turquie a les
moyens de fermer sa porte ce qu'elle n'a
pas souhaité faire pour des raisons
géopolitiques dans les mois qui ont
précédé donc en conclusion quelle
situation des peuples qui souffrent des
hommes qui meurent lors de leur exode
des mafias de passeurs qui
s'enrichissent et nous pays européens
nous avons fait comme si c'était la fin
de l'histoire alors que la géopolitique
reste un élément fondamental de
compréhension de l'histoire que nous
vivons aujourd'hui et donc nos pays et
l'Union européenne doit effectuer une
révolution mentale et comprendre que
pour exercer un rôle utile à la paix et
au développement dans le monde il faut
aussi comprendre les rapports de force
merci merci beaucoup
monsieur et maintenant je passe la
parole à if pascoot donc directeur des
politiques de migration et de mobilité à
l'Europan policy Center monsieur le
Président merci mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs bonjour merci pour cette
invitation pour venir discuter de cette
de cette question au combien sensible
depuis un certain nombre de mois et qui
risque évidemment de continuer à nous
intéresser et à être au sommet de
l'agenda politique européen des états-
membres pendant encore de de nombreuses
semaines malheureusement de nombreux
mois et peut-être de nombreuses années
euh
professeur Dumont faisait état d'une
erreur d'analyse à laquelle j'ajouterai
peut-être et certainement de la part de
l'Union européenne ce qui est
principalement le domaine que
j'aborderai dans le cadre de cette
courte présentation une une
impréparation une impréparation des
États-membres de l'Union européenne à la
situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui une impréparation qui tient
en deux éléments à mon avis pas
seulement mais principalement le premier
c'est l'incapacité des étatsmembres de
l'Union européenne de prendre en
considération la totalité des rapports
et avertissements sur la situation qui
était en train de se jouer à la au
voisinage immédiat de l'Union européenne
il ne s'agissait pas ici de lire les
différents rapports de quelques
organisations internationales qualifié
par certaines de droits lomistes mais
simplement aussi de lire les rapports
publiés par l'agence européenne Frontex
de lire les rapports publiés par le Haut
Commissariat aux réfugiés des Nations
Unies de lire les rapports du Programme
alimentaire mondial pour se rendre
compte que les millions de personnes qui
avaient quitté le conflit syrien mais
pas seulement iraakiens afghan éitréen
somalien étaient sur la route et que ils
étaient où ils avaient cherché une
protection temporaire entre guillemets
au plus près de la zone de conflit mais
que la situation dans laquelle il vivait
dans ces régions et dans ces pays-là
n'était plus supportable et que il
fallait chercher une des meilleures
conditions de vie ailleurs la totalité
des rapports indiquait en réalité que le
mouvement que nous avons vu apparaître à
partir de la fin de l'été 2015 était
tout sauf imprévisible je vous renverrai
aux différents rapports notamment du
commissariat des réfugiés aux Nations
Unies mais aussi de l'agence Frontex
agence Frontex qui disait au
3e trimestre
2014 parmi les 140000 syriens qui
résident en Égypte nombreux nombreux
sont ceux qui ont pris la route pour
aller vers le nord sous-entendu s'ils
sont déjà nombreux à être partis
d'autres partiront donc on avait en
réalité un ensemble d'éléments qui
permettait d'éclairer sur la situation
or personne n'a semble-t-il voulu
prendre en considération ce phénomène là
deuxième élément d'explication et qui me
semble important à soulever dans cette
enceinte c'est
la manière dont les États-membres de
l'Union européenne perçoivent en réalité
les questions migratoires il les
perçoivent de deux manières différentes
qui ne permettent pas d'apporter une
réponse appropriée à la situation
premier élément les États-membres de
l'Union européenne continuent à
considérer que les politiques
migratoires sont des politiques qui
relève de la souveraineté nationale ce
ne sont pas des questions européennes or
par définition un mouvement migratoire
est un mouvant transnational qui plus
est en direction d'un espace de liberté
de circulation un espace commun doit
faire l'objet d'une prise en compte et
d'une prise de décision
commune aussi longtemps que les
États-membres de l'Union européenne
considérons que la question migratoire
n'est pas une question européenne alors
nous ne serons pas capablebles de
répondre en commun à ces questions-l
deuxième élément qui à mon avis explique
ou peut expliquer l'état d'impréparation
c'est la logique qui commande à la mise
en œuvre de ces politique à la fois dans
les États-membres et par conséquent au
niveau de l'Union européenne pour le
dire assez simplement la question
migratoire au niveau de l'Union
européenne est bloqué dans une logique
affaires intérieures et bloqué dans une
logique ministère de
l'Intérieur or et la crise le démontre
ce qu'e qualifie à à juste titre ou pas
de de crise la situation démontre que ce
que nous vivons ici est tout sauf une
simple affaire d'affaires
intérieur pour le dire assez simplement
et pour donner une image la question
migratoire ne commence pas et ne se
termine pas à la frontière fut-elle la
frontière extérieure de l'Union
européenne la question migratoire
commence
loin avant la frontière c'est une
question de politique étrangère et le
professeur du monde l'a très clairement
souligné et je pense qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'expliquer cette chosel ici
dans cette enceinte c'est une question
de politique étrangère mais la question
migratoire continue longtemps après
l'arrivée sur le territoire et c'est une
question d'intégration ce qui veut dire
simplement que si l'on veut sérieusement
aborder la question migratoire il faut
aussi sérieusement penser la
coordination des différents postes
politiques de la politique étrangère à
la politique intérieure et aux
politiques sur les territoire et en
réalité la l'incapacité des
États-membres de l'Union européenne à
sortir de ce schéma les amis dans une
capacité à répondre à la situation qui
s'est déclenchée de manière brutale et
importante tente au mois d'août
septembre
2015 à défaut de planifier donc à défaut
d'agir les États-membres de l'Union
européenne se sont retrouvés dans une
situation de réaction et ici encore nul
besoin de dire que la réaction n'a
jamais tenu lieu de politique et donc on
s'est retrouvé à partir d'août septembre
2015 dans une situation où nous avons
cherché à réagir et sans pour autant
apporter les réponses adéquates et
nécessaires et sans pour autant que les
réponses qui ont été prises ou les
mesures qui ont été prises é été suivies
des faits et je terminerai ma
présentation par une présentation un
petit peu synthétique mais je pense que
nous pouvons aborder la gestion de cette
situation là sous trois
angles la réponse
immédiate celle que les États-membres de
l'Union européenne au travers des
institutions européennes ont cherché à
mettre en œuvre afin de répondre à la
situation et cette réponse immédiate a
pris tous les éléments d'une réponse
opérationnelle donc les États-membres de
l'Union européenne en commun ont cherché
à opérationnaliser une réponse alors on
l' vu en Méditerranée avec le triplement
de des fonds àoués à l'opération de
Triton nous l'avons vu aussi en
Méditerranée avec la création de cette
opération iuna for
sopia qui a pour but effectivement de
les réseaux de passeur et de détruire
les les navires ces dispositifs là sont
très certainement ceux qui ont produit
aujourd'hui le plus
d'effet Triton SAU Sofia SAU on est
parvenu visiblement en fonction des des
chiffres je n'ai pas l'exactitude des
chiffres mais à démantelé un certain
nombre de de navires donc ces deux
dispositifs semblent avoir été avoir
produit certains effets mais ce sont
peut-être les seuls parce que si on
regarde bien sur l'ensemble des mesures
qui ont été prise et dont on a essayé
qu'on a essayé de mettre en œuvre les
résultats sont très peu convaincants à
l'extérieur vous mentionniez monsieur le
professeur l'idée de venir en aide ou de
supporter les pays-tiers dans la manière
dont il gère les flux migratoires alors
il y a eu deux fonds fiduciaires qui ont
été créés un fond fiduciaire pour la
Syrie qui a été abondé à 50 % par
l'Union européenne et à 50 % par les
États-membres et l'objectif de l'abondé
à hauteur de 1 milliard d'euros a été
latin mais au sommet de la Valette nous
avons pris la décision de créer un fond
fiduciaire pour l'Afrique identifiant un
certain nombre de partenaires africains
avec lesquels il fallait travailler
notamment en terme de gestion des flux
migratoires et de développement l'idée
était d'allouer à ce fond fiduciaire
pour l'Afrique une somme de 3,6
milliards d'euros abondé pour partie par
l'Union européenne et abondé pour
l'autre partie par les états-membbres de
l'Union européenne la Commission
européenne a mobilisé un ensemble de
fonds et a mis au pot commun si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi 1,8 milliard d'euros
avant le sommet de la Valette les
États-membres de l'Union européenne
s'étaient engagés à abonder à hauteur de
1 millions d'euros après le sommet de la
Valette ce cette proposition de
financement n'a pas bougé autrement dit
il manque aujourd'hui de la part des
États-membres de l'Union européenne
l'équivalent de 1,7 milliard d'euros
pour le fameux fond UE Afrique donc on a
là un premier élément qui démontre la
difficulté de mettre en œuvre un
ensemble de mesures qui ont été adoptées
et qui tiennent essentiellement à la
rétisence d'un ensemble de partenaires
européens à participer en commun
peut-être aussi parce qu'ils n'ont pas
confiance dans les dispositifs qui ont
été mis en œuvre deuxième élément pour
l'aspect opérationnel ce qui relève de
la réaction au travers des hotspots de
la relocalisation et de l'accord UE
Turquie l'idée des Hotspot est une idée
qui en réalité avait été présentée par
la Commission européenne au mois de mai
2 201 suite au naufrage dramatique en
Méditerranée d'environ 1000 1000
personnes l'idée était effectivement
d'instituer ces centres d'accueil et
d'enregistrement pour ensuite pouvoir
relocaliser des
personnes les hotspots devaient
visiblement être établis relativement
facilement on s rendu compte en réalité
que cela été tout sauf facile parce
qu'il y a un ensemble de contraintes
matérielles et de terrain qui n'ont pas
permis de mettre en œuvre ses hotspots
rapidement deuxème élément la
participation au hotspot ou le
fonctionnement hotspot
requier la participation des autres
États-membres de l'Union européenne en
termes financiers en termees matériel et
en terme humain or ce que l'on ce que
l'on ce dont on se rend compte
aujourd'hui c'est que depuis la
conclusion de l'accord UE Turquie la
Commission européenne a fait un ensemble
de calculs en disant il nous faut tant
de personnes qui seraient envoyé par les
États-membres de l'Union européenne au
soutien des autorités grecques dans les
hotspot je voudrais simplement vous
donner quelques chiffres ici pour vous
montrer à quel point nous sommes loin du
compte
le Bureau Européen d'appui en matière
d'asile a demandé à ce que 400
interprètes soient envoyés sur les
hotspots les États-membres de l'Union
européenne collectivement ont proposé
d'envoyer 118 interprètes et aujourd'hui
63 seulement ont été déployés quand on
connaît la difficulté et la sensibilité
de la
question des personnes qui arrive pour
identifier s'il s'agit de demandeurs
d'asile de réfugiés ou de personnes qui
sont qui ont d'autres volontés la
question de l'interprétariat est
déterminante or nous n'avons pas les
moyens pour procéder aux entretiens
parce que nous ne disposons pas des
interprètes deuxième élément les experts
le Bureau Européen d'appui en matière
d'asile a demandé 472 experts 470 ont
été proposés par les étatsmemes les
États se sont engagés à en envoyer 470
aujourd'hui seul 67 sont arrivés ça
démontre la difficulté en réalité
d'établir un dispositif et de le faire
fonctionner avec
les moyens nécessaires parce que les
États-membres ne peuvent pas ou ne
veulent pas c'est selon participer à cet
effort commun je voudrais signifier ici
simplement l'idée
que la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
est une question qui évidemment et le
mot est était sur toutes les lèvres
depuis de nombreux mois est une question
de solidarité pas simplement en terme de
relocalisation mais en terme d'aide à la
Grèce à l'Italie de manière à ce que les
dispositifs puissent fonctionner cette
solidarité matérielle n'est pas encore
atteinte pour les relocalisations une
seule phrase suffira depuis les 8 mois
qui depuis les 8 derniers mois nous
n'avons pas encore atteint le chiffre de
1 % des personnes relocalisées sur les
160000 alors il ne faut pas perdre le
tableau tout en noir les relocalisations
doivent avoir un effet sur de années
peut-être que dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois nous
nous verrons une une capacité beaucoup
plus importante des États-membres à
contribuer effectivement à la
relocalisation des personnes je voudrais
simplement terminer sur deux aspects
puisque je vois que la le le temps
tourne sur le deuxème temps nous avons
vu la réponse immédiate à la situation
qui s'est traduite par une action
opérationnelle nous avons maintenant une
deuxième forme d'action qui est celle
d'adapter notre système à la situation
Schengen ou l'asile et ça c'est l'aspect
législatif c'est le temps législatif
c'est la modification du code- frontière
Schengen c'est la mise en œuvre d'un
corps européen de garde frontières et de
garde-côte c'est la nécessité de
modifier les règles Dublin c'est la
nécessité de modifier les règles
relatives à l'asile et tout ceci est un
temps d'adaptation qui est un temps
législatif et ce dispositif là prendra
du temps alors on a bon espoir que les
règles relatives à Schengen puissent
être modifiés assez rapidement et que le
Corps européen de garde frontière ou de
gardecôte puisse voir le jour assez
rapidement peut-être pas aussi
rapidement que ce que souhaiterait la
Commission européenne mais très
certainement à l'automne les règles
relatives à l'asile posent d'autres
questions fondamental il n'est pas tout
à fait certain aujourd'hui que l'on
s'entende sur la fameuse liste de pays
d'origine sûre la Turquie est-elle un
pays d'origine sûre les questions sont
sur la table et on voit bien que elles
embêtent les décideurs politiques et
notamment le Parlement européen mais
serontnous capable de modifier le
règlement Dublin et le système Dublin la
proposition qui a été présentée la
semaine passée par la Commission
européenne risque de rencontrer de
nombreuses oppositions et c'est pas le
chiffre magique des 250000 €
par demandeur d'asile réfugié qui va
simplifier les choses dernier
point
l'opérationnel le législatif et reste et
je terminerai d'une certaine manière
comme Monsieur le Professeur sur le long
terme le stratégique l'Union européenne
les États-membres de l'Union européenne
n'ont pas de vision stratégique sur ce
que doit être une politique européenne
d'asile et d'immigration ils sont comme
dans bien des domaines et dans bien des
États membres contraints par des logique
courttermiste nous étions parmi les
premiers et peut-être même les seuls en
janvier 2014 dans l'organisation pour
laquelle je travaille a indiqué au chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement que au moment
de la définition des orientations de
l'espace de liberté de sécurité de
justice il fallait entamer un travail de
long terme et pas simplement se poser la
question de savoir à quoi ressemblerait
la migration dans les 5 prochaines
années mais dans 10 15 20 ou 25
prochaines années la mobilité hum
humaine telle qu'elle se ente
aujourd'hui ne sera très certainement
pas la même demain un certain nombre
d'éléments vont jouer sur la mobilité
humaine dans les 10 15 20 25 prochaines
années ce ne sont pas simplement les
conflits et les et les questions
démographiques qui sont en jeu ce sont
évidemment les questions climatiques
mais l'urbanisation du monde est un
facteur de mobilité extraordinairement
important la montée de la classe moyenne
qui explose aujourd'hui est un facteur
de mobilité extraordinairement important
et comment peut-on établir une politique
publique de gestion des flux migratoires
sans avoir de vision de ce que à quoi
pourrait correspondre demain la mobilité
humaine donc ce travail-là n'a pas été
fait et il n'a pas été fait où il est en
train de commencer à être fait sur la
capacité comme je le disais tout à
l'heure d'avoir une une lecture
transversale de ce que doit être une
politique migratoire où commence-t-elle
elle ne commence pas sur le territoire
de l'Union européenne elle commence à
l'extérieur donc comment est-ce que nous
sommes en capacité de prévoir come
comment sommes-nous en capacité de
planifier comment sommes-nous en
capacité de répondre et elle se poursuit
sur le territoire des États-membres
comment organise-t-on la mobilité sur un
espace commun comment organise-t-on la
capacité des personnes qui arrivent à
accéder à un ensemble de services et
tout simplement de droits que le droit
de l'Union européenne leur accorde et
toutes ces questions-l sont aujourd'hui
des questions qui ne sont pas abordées
pour des raisons de calendrier électoral
de calendrier euh ou de ou de mandat et
sans que l'on se se pose véritablement
la question de ce à quoi pourrait
ressembler une politique publique de
l'Immigration et de l'asile européenne
dans le futur je vous
remercie merci beaucoup les questions
sont lourdes hein dernier point c'est
comment les démocraties sont-elles
capables de gérer le Moen long terme par
exemple mais sur ce sujet comme sur
beaucoup d'autres enfin on voit que
derrière chacun de vos sujets les
questions sont sont lourdes alors pour
éclairer aussi notre débat nous avons la
chance d'avoir deux co-présidents d'un
groupe de travail auquel je vais d'abord
donner la parole à Jacques lejeand d'une
part et à Gaetan Gorse d'autre part
monsieur le sénateur
leendre monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je vois tout d'abord remercier
les deux intervenants parce que leur
exposé m'a paru à la fois très clair et
très appuyé sur des constats à propos
des réalités et ça fait plaisir
de
voir d'entendre cette approche on peut
être chercheur et concret qu oui tout à
fait ça rassure toujours le
Parlement vous avez posé un certain
nombre de questions dénoncé par exemple
monsieur Dumont la non d'application du
code frontière Schengen dès l'origine
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire à
votre avis pour quelle raison l'Union
européenne après avoir établi ce cet
accord a presque tout de suite renoncer
à l'appliquer car je crois que les
populations se rendent compte qu'on
prend des textes et qui ne sont pas
appliqués et que c'est une des raisons
de l'irritation de certaines popul de la
population à l'égard des règles adoptées
par l'Union européenne deuxième
remarque vous avez
euh parlé
des de de la politique qui a été mise en
place recherché avec la Turquie à propos
de ces ces ces immigrants moi ce qui m'a
frappé en visitant par exemple le camp
de
Calais c'est que la majorité des
réfugiés qui sont là ne sont pas des
Syriens que les Syriens présents se
plaignent d'être minoritaires et mal
perçu par les autres et que par
conséquent on ne peut pas traiter
uniquement d'un problème de réfugié
fuyant un pays en guerre ce qui se
comprend et qui est quelque chose mais
nous avons mêlé à ceci des personnes qui
fuit des pays où ell ne se sentent
peut-être pas à l'aise il y avait par
exemple des Afghans ou des Pakistanais
des héritréens et des gens probablement
d'Afrique de l'Ouest également et leur
problématique relevait de par de de de
situation différentes on a beaucoup
parlé depuis quelques temps de la route
de l'Est et de la route des Balcans mais
les premiers drames qui se sont produits
ne n'étaient pas sur la route de l'Est
c'est d'abord les naufrages en
Méditerranée centrale à propos
desquelles on a mis en place quelques
opérations navales parfois ambigu
puisqu'elle nous amène à la fois à
sauver des vies ce qui est essentiel et
bien évidemment et incontestable mais
d'une certaine manière aussi être
utilisé par les passeurs pour faire
faire par les marines européennes une
partie de leur travail en leur
enlaissant bien sûr les bénéfices donc
problème s'agit-il à ce moment-là
d'amener les gens que l'on sauve dans un
pays européen ou de les ramener au point
de départ ce qui est un problème et qui
à ce moment-là risque de nous mettre en
non conformité avec les règles
juridiques que nous avons accepté est-ce
qu'il est logique par exemple que la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
puisse se prononcer sur ces questions et
qu'une certaine manière elle ne laisse
pas aux États la possibilité de
déterminer une politique étatique ou de
déterminer une politique européenne
entre état j'ai entendu à l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe des
critiques assez vives émises par le
Commissaire aux Droits de l'Homme du
Conseil de l'Europe sur
l'accord turquieunion européenne des
réserves également du secrétaire général
de du Conseil de l'Europe et j'observe
enfin que cette institution qui est la
seule à regrouper tous les pays
européens et la Turquie n'a pas été du
tout concerné par tout ceci et qu'on
traite on parle de Schengen à certain
moment on parle de l'Union européenne à
d'autres on quand on parle de Schengen
l'Angleterre n'est pas concerné or
l'Angleterre
a a en son sein une des plus fortes
communautés de réfugiés d'origine et on
sait bien aussi que ce qui motive les la
recherche de destination des migrants
c'est l'existence de grandes communautés
où ils ont des parents c'est le cas
actuellement avec la Grande-Bretagne
alors est-ce que vous pourvez nous
éclairer un peu sur ces points merci
gaor merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs pour votre constat et sa
lucidité qui n'était pas toujours
encourageante enfin qui était nécessaire
au regard de de la situation que vous
avez
décrite deux remarques la première vous
nous dites notamment monsie PASC
monsieur vous nous dites au fond c'est
une question de politique étrangère que
cette question d'immigration c'est
évident le problème c'est qu'il y a pas
de politique étrangère européenne et
qu'on a pas l'outil à partir duquel on
peut organiser la réflexion et l'action
donc la question qui dispose à partir de
là c'est ce qu'il ne faut pas imaginer
un autre cadre de réflexion et de
coopération est c'est une coopération
renforcée est-ce que les grands États
ceux qui étaient et ceux qui sont au
fond les plus directement concernés par
ces enjeux et qu'on les moyens d'agir ne
devrait pas imaginer un autre cadre de
réflexion et d'action que celui que
propose les dispositifs actuels de
l'Union dans lequel évidemment les
résistances pour les tas de raisons sont
nombreuses de ce point de vue quel rôle
la France pourrait-elle jouer quel rôle
joue--elle quel rôle pourrait-elle jouer
en a eu le sentiment qu'elle était quand
même relativement discrète sur ces
sujets sans doute comme pour tous les
autres États pour des raisons
politique mais en on voit bien les
limites de l'exercice c'est que le
problème on a B le mettre un peu de côté
avec l'accord UE Turquie on a un répi il
reviendra et ça c'est ça donne le le
cadre de ma deuxième question c'est que
vous avez
évoqué les sujets monsieur Dumont liés
aux crises sur lesquel il faudrait
évidemment agir et j'indiquis la
difficulté pour l'Union européenne de se
concerter pour le faire et peut-être la
nécessité d'envisager un autre cadre
mais ces crises ponctuelles ne
sont-elles pas que l'annonce d'autres
phénomènes migratoires qui auront
d'autres causes vous avez les causes
climatiques on sait aussi le désordre
croissant qui règne en Afrique de
l'Ouest avec les conséquences que tout
ça peut produire autrement dit nous ne
sommes pas là confrontés à un problème
auquel on pourrait essayer espérer
apporter une réponse à partir des
situations qui font naître ce problème
c'est sûr qu'il faut y travailler
essayer d'avoir une concordance entre
notre politique militaire notre
politique étrangère et notre politique
migratoire mais on voit bien que
d'autres problèmes vont se poser très
vite est-ce que ça ne doit pas nous
amener à reconsidérer la façon et dont
nous travaillons avec ces territoires je
pense notamment sur l'Afrique de l'Ouest
est-ce que là encore une initiative
française européenne ne serait pas
indispensable en terme d'accompagnement
et de développement mais comme on sait
que la poussée démographique et les
difffés économiques vont être t que ça
ne suffira pas à résoudre la question
d'immigration est-ce que nous pas
réfléchir à d'autres types d'échanges et
de flux migratoirees avec ces
territoires et est-ce que c'est
envisageable à la fois techniquement et
politiquement de penser que nous
pourrions organiser les arrivées et les
départs sur le sol européen des
populations qui autrement vont continuer
et à taper à la porte de l'Union
européenne enfin dernière question sur
la le la définition même du réfugié ce
que disait Jacques lejeand montre bien
toujours l'incertitude qui peut exister
nous appliquons des dispositifs qui ont
été conçus dans un autre contexte
géostratégique face à d'autres situation
et nous voyons bien que cette définition
du réfugié est aujourd'hui en permanence
soumise à des contradictions et des
questions il y a le débat évidemment sur
le pays d'origine sûr mais il y a plus
généralement la distinction entre le
réfugié politique et le réfugié
économique sur nos amis g par exemple la
situation est à la fois politique et
économique c'est extrêmement difficile
d'apporter une réponse satisfaisante et
donc en se donnant pour point de passage
obligatoire l'examen de la situation cas
par cas ce qui est une bonne chose mais
au regard de critères qui sont
extrêmement difficiles à démontrer
est-ce qu'on ne rend pas encore plus
complexe la solution du problème est-ce
qu'on devrait pas accepter de le traiter
dans son ensemble et de renoncer à faire
cette distinction non pas de manière
systématique mais de considérer qu'on
doit aborder le problème dans sa
globalité parce qu'il va devenir
impossible de le traiter de manière
aussi euh si
spécifiqueè
j'ai encore là donc ce que je vous
propose c'est d'arrêter à 10h40 pour
laisser 10 minutes à chacun des orateurs
pour pouvoir répondre avant notre
prochaine audition à 11h Jacques
Gautier merci monsieur le Président oui
félicitations merci pour cette
intervention à de voix qui abordé ce
sujet de fond je voudrais rebondir sur
ce qu'a évoqué nos deux collègues sur
bien sûr l'erreur d'analyse au départ le
manque de réactivité mais aussi le le
manque de vision stratégique à long
terme qui nous concerne mais je voudrais
revenir sur la différence des deux
immigrations celle qui vient du Levant
dont on sent qu'elle est avant tout
humanitaire lié à une menace physique
liée à la guerre civile que vous évoquz
et celle qui vient du sud Sahel qui est
totalement économique et qui perdurera
même si un jour nous arrivons à régler
le le problème du Levant donc quelle est
votre analyse par rapport à ces deux
flux migratoires qui sont divers l'un
durant de beaucoup plus longtemps que
l'autre et risquant de perdurer beaucoup
plus longtemps et on voit bien les
limites de sopia qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure tant que nous ne passons pas à
la phase 3 nous sommes lié un peu à être
des passeurs complémentaires des
passeurs et on voit donc la difficulté
de
l'exercice vous avez aussi évoqué le
problème de la nécessité de la proximité
pour éviter immigration et réimmigration
et vous avez parlé des trois pays qui
ont absorbé le plus de réfugiés Turquie
Jordanie et Liban avec la
déstabilisation qu'on l'envoie surtout
au Liban la question que je me pose
depuis longtemps et je sens bien le côté
incongru de la question c'est si on veut
éviter une immigration et si on veut
permettre le retour de desmigrants
lorsque la situation s'est améliorée
l'idéal c'est d'arriver à le garder au
plus près de son territoire est-ce que
dans les zones du nord de l'Irak c'est
sécurisé et est-ce que même en étant
presque provocateur dans les zones les
plus à l'ouest de la Syrie sécurisée
est-ce que le Haut Commissariat au
réfugiés des Nations Unies soutenu par
l'Europe ne pourrait pas créer en accord
avec les partis des camps de réfugiés
qui permettrai d'éviter de quitter la
Syrie et de quitter l'Irak et
faciliterait donc le retour je suis bien
conscient que c'est un véritable
difficulté politique et géopolitique
mais je crois que c'est c'est la réponse
la plus simple à ce problème
d'immigration merci Jean-Marie Boquel
oui merci avec mon collègue Jeanny
Lorjou et quelques collègues nous avons
commis il y a 3 ans un rapport au sein
de la commission l'Afrique et notre
avenir et bon à l'époque nous étions
dans un certain optimisme il y avait une
croissance continue même si nous avons
été lucid sur les les enjeux et les
risques et nous avons notamment évoqué
l'enjeu démographique aujourd'hui on
voit bien que les choses se tendent il y
a à la fois la dimension de sécurité la
dimension économique et évidemment de
d'immigration infraafricaine très
importante mais aussi maintenant à
travers le Maghreb d'immigration très
forte vers l'Europe et quand on voit les
les perspectives démographiques les
perspectives climatiques les enjeux de
guerre et de paix et cetera et la
mauvaise gouvernance qui reste encore
très prignante même s'il y a des progrès
ici ou là là on a évidemment un tableau
qui va bien bien au-delà de de tout ce
que vous avez pu évoquer
et j'aurais été content de connaître un
peu je dirais votre vision de de cet
avenir quoi parce que là
franchement c'est c'est une autre
histoire merci Christian
Cambon merci
président
sur sur le long terme et est-ce queon
peut
pas est-ce qu'on a pas le devoir de
revisiter les politiques de
développement euh qui sont en quelque
sorte
euh le la transparence enfin la
signification d'un d'un échec notamment
des pays européens en la matière euh
dans ce domaine est-ce qu'on va
constituer des est-ce qu'on va élaborer
des politiques d'immigration euh qui
n'ont du reste pas vraiment le soutien
des opinions publiques regardons tout
autour de nous regardons des pays comme
l'Autriche voyons ce qui est en train de
s'y passer dans le même temps on
continue à engloutir des sommes
colossales euh en matière de
développement et de coopération enfin 30
milliards pour le Fond Européen pour le
11e Fed rien que cette somme si on y
ajoute le fond sida et bien d'autres or
on voit bien que une bonne part de cette
immigration comme le disait Jacques est
lié à une motivation économique pour
nombre d'entre eux des régimes
autoritaires il y en a toujours eu en
héritrée en Somalie ce sont pas quand
même des parangons de démocratie or
jamais on a vu autant euh d'immigration
moi j'été de passage il y a un mois à
Mayotte quand on voit ce qui est en
train de s'y passer avec plus de 130 ou
140000 clandestins qui arrivent y
compris d'Afrique et qui rentent par
cette porte sur le territoire européen
c'est pas tellement le régime des
Comores ou des régimes africains qu'il
contestent c'est simplement qu' ne
peuvent pas manger et on se souvient
bien que le petit tunisien vendeur
d'Orange qui s'est fait brûlé ne
demandait pas plus de démocratie il
voulait simplement pouvoir vivre de son
travail c'était ça l'origine de cette de
de de ce printemps de ce printemps Arab
donc quelque part est-ce qu'il ne faut
pas revisiter revoir sérieusement ces
politiques de dével développement le
patriarche maronite de du Liban que nous
recevions avec le président Larcher
disait avanthier c'est pas les
dispositif d'accueil c'est pas les
politiques des visas que nous voulons
c'est simplement donner à la fois les
conditions de paix et de développement
pour que ces gens restent chez eux parce
que de toute façon si on les accueille
chez ici en Europe ils ne reviendront
pas contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit ils ne reviendront pas et à la
deuxième génération il a expliqué
amplement qu'ils oublient le fait qu'ils
étaient libanais ils s'installent ici et
et et qui viendra les remplacer bien
évidemment ce sera les daesh enfin
toutes tous ces gens qui eux ont besoin
effectivement d'implanter leur influence
sur ce territoire donc en d'autres
termees est-ce qu'il faut pas revoir
fondamentalement pas simplement au
niveau français la France fait ce
qu'elle peut elle en a fait beaucoup
plus que bien d'autres mais une
politique européenne et une politique
des pays occidentaux en matière de
développement parce qu'encore une fois
les sommes sont considérables hein les
boucles du Niger ont ont englouti des
milliards et des milliards et quand on
voit la situation du Mali on se demande
franchement où est passé tout cet argent
donc est-ce qu'il faudrait pas là
avoir un autre regard sur la politique
de développement puisque la première
nécessité de tous ces peuples leur
premier le premier désir c'est de vivre
en dignité de pouvoir manger et de
pouvoir s'y développer quel est votre
sentiment sur ce sujet merci alain
GOURNAC je voudrais remercier les deux
intervenants qui ont été très
intéressants et très complémentaires et
après Christian Cambon puisque vous
réalisez des études est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui lui on peut avoir une
évaluation de ceux alors je parle pas
simplement des Syriens c'est très
important parce qu'il en arrive de de
partout de ceux qui sont amenés à rester
et ceux qui sont amenés à retourner vers
leur pays parce que je sais pas s'ils
seront très heureux je partage l'analyse
de fait venir ici viennent ici pour
essayer de trouver manger du travail
ainsi de suite mais c'est pas c'est pas
leur souhait profond est-ce que vous
vous avez une évaluation je sais que
c'est pas facile et la deuxième question
est simple ça a été évoqué je crois que
Jacques l'a évoqué c'est il y a un
projet de contrôle des côtes libienne
alors là ce serait pas pour faire la
moitié du travail des passeurs mais qui
serait de les ramener parce que ce
serait assez près euh de la des des des
des côtes libyennes est-ce que vous
pensez que ça c'est une chose je passe
je je je pose cette question particulier
dans ce souci de ne plus engraisser les
passeurs parce que Monsieur le
Professeur les la somme la somme que
vous avez avancé m'a assommé merci de
cette rapidité Joseph
dueux monsieur le Président merci
infiniment à nos deux intervenants par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit Monsieur
Pasco vraiment vous avez raison
d'insister sur la non volonté de
l'Europe vraiment de saisir la réalité
de la
situation nous sommes un certain nombre
ségé au Conseil d'Europe 47 pays membres
dans les 28 vraiment moi je voudrais
dire ici à quel point il y a eu un dénis
de la part de l'Europe absence de
solidarité totale et pourtant le seul
discours que l'on entendait il était
humanitaire parce qu'il fallait surtout
pas s'engager plus loin et dans la
réalité un véritable déniis les
explications parce que vous avez dit
parler de solidarité vous avez dit n'a
pas voulu vous avez raison faut insister
égo individualisme nationalisme
malheureusement c'est à ajouter au
tableau gris que nous pouvons faire de
l'Europe aujourd'hui je l'ai vécu de
façon dramatique par moment cette
absence de volonté la deuxième remarque
monsieur le professur du vous avez
parfaitement raison de dire que les
hotpots auraient dû être établis dans
les pays qui étaient les premiers pays
d'accueil Liban Turquie
et Jordanie et là il fallait les aider
vraiment ça non plus nous ne l'avons pas
fait et par rapport à la Turquie
j'aurais presque envie de dire qu'il y
avait un autre dénis tellement nous
n'avons pas dit à quel point les efforts
de la Turquie étaient
exceptionnels avec vraiment un une
intention politique hein derrière d'en
faire une vitrine mais enfin l'effort
était là par contre professeur dubond
moi je suis allé à kobané en juin 2014
je ne sais pas si c'était le meilleur
endroit pour reconstruire cet îot coincé
entre daesh d'un côté et la Turquie de
l'autre mais les hot spots dans les pays
frontaliers voisins oui il y avait une
proposition de la France et de Laurent
fabus de les aménager très vite en
suivant les zones pacifié dans les zones
de conflit mais insistons sur ce que
nous avons à faire si vous êtes entendu
mieux que nous insistez plus que vous le
faites alors ma question quand même pose
un autre problème concernant la France
pays de droit d'asile il y a eu plus
plus d'offres de la part de la France
que de demande vous avez une analyse à
faire là-dessus et surtout ça a été dit
par getangor et pas les autres c'est le
moment pour vous d'intervenir et de nous
aider anticiper sur les problèmes liés
au réchauffement climatique parce ce
sera plus des milliers ce sera des
millions de personnes qui seront mises à
mouvement peut-être que c'est le moment
d'insister davantage de votre part et de
nous aider à définir les
stratégies merci Claude
maluray je vais vous permettre de gagner
du temps sur l'horaire monsieur le
Président les questions que je comptais
poser on voit bien d'ailleurs qu'on est
tous qu'il y a deux ou trois questions
principales qui reviennent les questions
que je voulais poser ont été posées donc
je vous propose de passer auè suiv merci
chers collègue mariefançoise spérol du
monde
oui merci messieur pour les pour les
éléments de réflexion que vous nous avez
apporté ce matin euh et qui qui montre
bien que que les raisons les raisons des
migrations sont multiples Jacques Le
Gendre vient de le dire et qu'elles vont
se pososer à nous sur la durée pour la
multiplicité justement de ces raisons il
nen reste pas moins que toutes ces
personnes-là si les raisons de leur
migration sont diverses elles ont une
expérience commune qui est l'expérience
de cette vulnérabilité extrême et
permanente à laquelle faisait référence
Anna arent dans un contexte différent
mais qui est bien toujours la même face
à cela nous observons en ce moment un
raiddissement des des opinions dans
l'espace Schengen rédissement en France
rédissement en Allemagne rédissement en
Italie et le scénario inconcevable il y
a 2 ans d'une remise en cause des
accords de Schengen et maintenant à
notre porte alors ma question elle est
simple est-ce que face à cela les
valeurs fondatrices de l'Europe vont
résister est-ce que le le tableau gris
dont parlait ma collègue Josette Durieux
il y a quelques minutes va
inéluctaableement se durcir en Europe ou
bien sinon quels sont les leviers à
activer pour que nous puissions remettre
l'Europe sur les bons rails et faire
ensemble que ce qui est fondateur de
l'espace européen le reste bien
c'est-à-dire le partage d'un certain
nombre de valeurs un idéal commun Michel
Billou merci oui merci monsieur le
Président écoutez en ma qualité de de
rapporteur d'une mission commune
d'information sur l'accord
UE Turquie vous me permettrez de vous
interroger juste sur ce sujet qui est un
petit élément de la question dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui mais qui a quand
même une certaine importance à savoir
s'il s'agit d'une tentative de de
réponse ponctuelle à un problème
localisé ou s'il s'agit d'une tentative
d'élaborer un modèle de de de réponse au
au flux migratoire donc j'aurais juste
deux questions très très générales une
relative au au droit d'asile et l'autre
relative peut-être donc au rôle
particulier de l'Allemagne au au sein de
l'Union européenne sur ce sujet
concernant le le le droit d'asile en
renvoyant en Turquie des personnes en
demande de protection internationale ce
qui est tout à fait
inédit l'Union européenne ne
méconnaît-elle pas ses obligations en
matière de droit d'asile et même si ce
n'était pas le cas pensez-vous que les
conditions matérielles humaines sont
remplies que ce soit en Grèce ou en
Turquie pour que ce droit d'asile soit
effectivement respecté mon autre
question concerne je dirais les
conditions de négociation et et
notamment le rôle très très particulier
de de l'Allemagne puisquon a plutôt le
sentiment que c'est un accord
allemagne-Turquie qui a été
négocié pensez-vous que ce qui justifie
la démarche de ces pays tient dans
l'idée de d'avoir un rôle de leadership
positif en l'Union européenne ou au
contraire est une réaction un peu
désespéré à la passivité et au manque
d'implication des autres États-membres
je vous remercie merci Hubert Falco
oui monsieur le Président
merci l'analyse qui vient de de nous
être faite est claire et préoccupante je
vais pas revenir sur tout ce qui vient
d'être d'être
dit j'ai écouté mon collègue qui qui
parlait effectivement puisqu'il y a
beaucoup travaillé de l'Afrique en
disant l'Afrique est notre avenir moi je
dirais que l'Afrique est une poudrière
et l'Afrique est le problème à venir euh
je suis un Européen convaincu donc je
l'ai toujours été mais je suis choqué
d'entendre comme dans votre analyse vous
en avez fait le constat
que la question migratoire n'est pas
européenne la question de la couleur des
fraises est européenne la question
migratoire n'est pas européenne donc
pour un Européen convaincu je suis
choqué donc je voulais avoir votre avis
sur
l'Algérie les menaces les menaces qui
qui qui qui
arrivent
donc comment allonsnous faire face nous
qui
sommes en face de l'algérievez les côtes
méditerranéennes sont totalement en face
de l'Algérie je crois que c'est le
problème à venir et le problème à venir
très rapidement merci j
Jord tout dernièrement donc le 6 mai
dernier Jean-Claude Junker a fait part
donc de toutes ses craintes par rapport
à la politique donc que mettrait en
place donc l'Autriche par rapport au col
du Brenner en mettant un dispositif
antimigrant il a qualifié comme vous
l'avez fait messieurs dans des termes
très directs cette catastrophe indiquant
donc toutes les répercussions qu'elle
pourvrait avoir tant sur le plan
économique que sur le plan humain je
souhaitais savoir comment donc vous
abordiez donc cette question et quelles
conséquences cela pourrait avoir
notamment donc sur le plan européen mais
sur le plan
français merci et le dernier mot un
seul vraiment un mot c'est le débat qui
m'a amené à à à poser cette question
euh naturellement l'Europe plaî coupable
en quelque
sorte ceci dit moi je me pose la
question
euh au nom des vertus morales que nous
portons au nom de ce qui a fait la
construction européenne c'est d'une
évidence absolue au nom de la politique
elle ne s'est pas donné une politique
communautaire de ce point de vue-là et
donc naturellement elle avance dispersé
et plus elle avance dispersé et plus
elle séparpira et donc le risque
qu'évoqué Marie-Françoise Pérol Dumont
est évident donc moi je veux bien
l'Europe par sa proximité en en quelque
sorte à cette responsabilité mais le
monde est le monde où est l'ONU dans
cette affaire question
euh tout à fait fondamental d'autres
pays peuvent estimer avoir une
responsabilité y compris sur ces régions
euh où ils ont à la fois une une
histoire et une activité alors
n'interprétez pas ce que je veux dire en
disant on va se dédoigner facilement en
disant c'est aux autres de faire et pas
à nous pas du tout je pense que vraiment
on a à faire mieux que ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à présent mais pour autant ne
portons pas en quelque sorte seul cette
responsabilité utilisons les les
créneaux qui existent je sait que l'ONU
s'intéresse à ces questions migratoires
depuis toujours et donc où est-elle
aujourd'hui dans cette question
particulière qui touche exclusivement
l'Europe merci beaucoup alors monsieur
le professeur monsieur le chercheur
alors peut-être qu'on peut commencer
dans l'autre sens non alors comme ça
monsieur le professeur vous prendrez les
questions qui n'ont pas été traité
par merci pour ces très nombreuses
questions je ne suis pas certain que
nous allons parvenir à répondre à toutes
celle d'entre elles
mais j'imagine monsieur le professeur
que vous répondrez à celle auquell je
n'ai pas pu
répondre donc je vais essayer de les
aborder où est où est l'ONU évidemment
l'ONU travaille sur C sur ces questions
là discute beaucoup mais sur les actions
je pense que
ça ça ça ça condue sur la question de
savoir quel est le rôle en réalité de la
communauté internationale face à cette
situation là évidemment l'Union
européenne essaie de de travailler mais
on voit qu'un ensemble d'autres acteurs
de la région du golf mais plus largement
ne participe pas véritablement à à
l'effort nécessaire alors on entend he
c'est c'est toujours très intéressant de
se rendre compte que en fonction du côté
duquel on se se trouve de la barrière
soit c'est une Europe fortresse soit
c'est une Europe passoir je ne crois ni
à l'un ni à l'autre et si
on considérer que il s'agit d'une Europe
fortresse si on prend et si on regarde
un petit peu une carte du monde il n y a
pas que l'Europe qui soit fortresse hein
le Japon est une forteresse l'Australie
est une forteresse les pays du Golf
aussi donc en réalité on on fait porter
sur l'Union européenne mais parce qu'on
la regarde et c'est et c'est encore
heureux j'espère qu'on la regardera
encore longtemps mais beaucoup de
beaucoup de mots qu'elle qu'elle partage
et que d'autres
euh portent de manière encore plus
violente
qu'elle-même
euh sur l'accord UE Turquie alors mon
analyse est relativement relativement
simple hein si l'on voudrait euh
schématiser les choses laaccord Turquie
porte sur trois catégories de personnes
les personnes en situation irrégulière
celle-ci qui arriverait de Turquie vers
la Grèce euh on peut imaginer le cas
d'un Algérien par exemple qui ne demande
pas l'asile et dont il est manifeste que
cette personne n'est pas autorisée
entrer à résider en Grèce cette personn
là ne pose pas véritablement de problème
en terme juridique puisqu'elle sera
renvoyée vers la vers le pays dont elle
vient soit sur la base de l'accord de
réadmission grèce-turquie soit sur la
base demain de l'accord des réadmissions
Union européenne tururquie donc de ce
point de vue-là c'est peut-être le cas
de figure le plus le plus facile et on
voit bien d'ailleurs que les retours qui
ont été organisés depuis la Grèce depuis
depuis la mise en œuvre effective de la
déclaration qui n'est pas un accord
union européenne-turquie ne concerne que
des personnes qui n'ont pas fait acte de
demande d'asile et dont on a considéré
qu'ell n'était pas autorisé à rentrer à
sé journé en Grèce les deux questions
principales qui se posent c'est
l'utilisation des concepts de pays de
premier asile et de pays tiers sû parce
que ces concepts là en réalité
concernent deux types de euh deux
catégories de personnees prenons le
concept de pays de premierère asile je
suis citoyen syrien qui est qui a obtenu
une protection en Turquie protection
dite temporaire j'arrive en Grèce et je
demande je dépose une demande d'asile
auprès des autorités grecques ces
dernières la considère comme étant
inadmissible au motif que je viens d'un
pays de premier asile c'est-à-dire un
pays dans lequel j'ai obtenu une
protection cette possibilité là existe
dans le droit de l'Union européenne sauf
que elle ne peut-être utilisée qu'à la
faveur d'une disposition c'est-à-dire
que l'on considère que la protection qui
est octroyée dans le pays-tiers en
l'occurrence en Turquie est suffisante
et toute la question se pose du
caractère suffisant ou pas de la
protection qui est accordée au syriens
mais à d'autres personnes en Turquie de
mon point de vue la logique voudrait que
si les étatsmembres de l'Union
européenne acceptte effectivement de
renvoyer une personne dans le besoin de
protection est reconnu vers un pays
tiers c'est que les États-membres de
l'Union européenne considèrent que la
protection insuffisante c'est-à-dire que
le niveau de protection qui est garanti
en Turquie est comparable peut-être pas
identique mais comparable à celui qui
est octroyé dans l'Union européenne or
je ne suis pas tout à fait certain
qu'aujourd'hui le statut la protection
et les droits qui sont garantis aux
personnes sous protection temporaire en
Turquie soient les mêmes que ceux qui
sont garantis sur le territoire de
l'Union Européenne donc de ce point de
vuelà la notion le concept de pays de
pays de premier asile me semble être
discutable et je ne sais pas si on peut
qualifier la Turquie de premier pays
d'asile deuxème cas de figure les pays
tiers sûrs c'est l'idée selon laquelle
reprenons l'exemple d'un citoyen syrien
personne qui arrive depuis la Turquie en
Grèce dépose une demande d'asile les
autorités grecques considèrent que la
demande d'asile est inadmissible au
motif que la personne provient d'un pays
tiers sûr c'est-à-dire un pays dont on
aurait pu considérer que un pays dans
lequel la personne aurait pu déposer une
demande d'asile là aussi ce dispositif
existe au nom du droit de l'Union
européenne dans la directive procédure
et il la directive procédure liste un
ensemble de conditions pour pouvoir
qualifier un paystiers de sûr parmi ces
conditions figure la condition
d'appliquer la Convention de Genève sur
le statut des réfugiés or tout le monde
sait très bien que la Turquie a une
réserve géographique sur la convention
de 51 puisqu'elle ne l'applique qu'aux
européens donc de ce simple fait on ne
peut pas considérer que la Turquie
puisse être considérée comme un pays
tiers sûr juridiquement ce qui veut dire
aujourd'hui que la déclaration Union
européenne Turquie c'est-à-dire
l'engagement des deux parties à agir et
l'engagement de l'Union européenne via
la Grèce à utiliser des concept de pays
tir sû des pays de première asile de mon
point de vue est juridiquement
contestable
mais la réponse ne pourra pas être
donnée ni par les États-membres de
l'Union européenne qui ont signé cette
déclaration ni par la Commission
européenne qui fait le service
aprèsvente de la de la déclaration mais
par un juge et seul le juge sera à même
de dire si la Turquie remplit ses
conditions juge grec ou au besoin juge
de l'Union européenne au travers d'une
question préjudicielle et ce ce n'est
que dans quelques jours semaines ou
moins que nous aurons cette réponse là
et en attendant on voit bien que la
difficulté est telle que le nombre de
renvois de Grèce depuis la Turquie de
demandeur d'asile ou de personnes sous
protection temporaire ne se réalise pas
parce qu'en réalité on ne sait pas et on
attendra que le juge juste pour la pour
pour la pour le plaisir de la discussion
et et la manière dont fonctionnent les
choses on se rend compte aujourd'hui que
un juge de première instance grec et
tout tout à fait capable en considérant
que la Turquie n'est pas un pays tiers
sûr de renverser la décision de 28 chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement accompagné par
le président du Conseil européen le
président de la Commission européenne
voilà ce à quoi nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui et pour revenir sur votre
deuxième point quel est le rôle de de
cet accord je pense que cet accord est
est un accord qui est de
communications double à la fois
l'adresse des citoyens européens en
disant regardez nous nous chargeons de
cette question là et apparemment à
l'adresse des passeurs en disant
regardez la la route greco-turque est
désormais fermée mais que cette routeel
soit fermée aujourd'hui de la même
manière que la route des Balcans soit
soit d en fermé ça n'empêchera pas les
personnes poussées par le désespoir
d'emprunter d'autres voies et on se
retrouvera à d'une certaine manière à la
case départ en avril 2015 1000 personnes
meurent en Méditerranée parce que elles
embarquent sur de fraises esquiv et pire
encore souvenez-vous hein c'était il y a
un an à peine nous avons vu un modus
operandi que nous n'avions jamais vu
auparavant des cargos remplis de
personnes
lancés moteur à fond sur les côtes sans
pilote voilà le caractère industriel de
l'horreur
humaine allons-nous retomber dans ces
situations là ça ce sont les questions
qui se posent quand on de l'Allemagne il
est tout à fait évident que l'Allemagne
a d'une part exercé un leadership
politique seul de manière positive et de
manière négative seul parce que vircha
fendas d'Angela Merkel est sur le plan
des valeurs ce qu'il fallait faire
quelles sont nos valeurs quelle est
notre histoire la migration est
l'histoire de de l'Europe entière pas
simplement de l'Union européenne mais du
continent elle a existé elle existe elle
continuera à exister quels sont nos
valeur vis-vis de ce phénomène le
problème du virchafendas c'est que on a
peut-être oublié que nous avons un
espace liberté de circulation commun
nous sommes en train d'essayer d'établir
un marché européen du travail donc
toutes les questions qui relèvent de la
question migratoires sont aujourd'hui
des questions communes et on ne peut pas
agir de manière unilatérale alors
positivement sur le terrain des baleurs
comme l'a fait la la chancelière ou
négativement sur le terrain sécuritaire
comme le font Victor Orban et d'autres
et d'autres personnes donc dans un
contexte commun l'
l'unilatéralisme est un problème et
aujourd'hui madame la chancellère Merkel
en disant nous allons accueillir s'est
retrouvé bien seul en réalité quand elle
s'est retourné pour avoir l'appui de ses
partenaires européens où était la France
où étaient les Pays-Bas où était
l'Italie l'Espagne personne elle était
seule et donc elle a D faire face à une
autre difficulté une difficulté interne
c'est de dire face à l'arrivée un nombre
très important de personnes sur le
territoire allemand et bien il faut
faire tomber les chiffres et faire
tomber les chiffres
c'est l'accord la négociation avec la
avec la Turquie donc on a un message
politique aujourd'hui à l'adresse des
citoyens européens et des citoyens
allemands en disant regardez les
chiffres tombent effectivement il est
tout à fait significatif aujourd'hui
quand on prend les communiqués de presse
Frontex de voir que les le nombre d'
arriver à chuter mais il augmente par
ailleurs hein mais on a un message
politique relativement fort je
terminerai sur la dernière minute qui me
reste sur une question beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus large et qui relève en
réalité de la capacité des États-membres
de l'Union européenne dans le cadre des
institutions communes d'organiser et de
prévoir euh il est il y a peut-être deux
voire trois cercles concentriques il y a
un premier cercle aujourd'hui hein il a
été fait mention de de l'Algérie et je
ne cacherai pas les propos d' d'un
éminent
géopolitique géopolitiste ou
géopolitologue avec qui nousous
entretenions en réunion fermée à à
Bruxelles qui disait nous avons déjà
beaucoup de mal à gérer la situation
syrienne on a beaucoup de mal à gérer
une crise il va il va falloir gérer
cette crise rapidement parce que deux
crises à la fois c'est pas possible et
cet éminent
spécialiste disait très clairement le
prochain sur la liste c'est l'Algérie et
comme vous le disiez l'Algérie c'est euh
il y a plus qu'à traverser la
Méditerranée donc on va avoir une
question qui va se poser assez
rapidement et je n'évoque pas ici la
question de la Libye donc on a une
première ligne de questionnement qui est
une un questionnement d'ordre de
déstabilisation politique de régions qui
vont créer potentiellement des euh des
réfugiés des exilés la deuxième ligne de
de résonnance c'est celle sur sur la
zone un petit peu plus au sud hein le le
Sahel et l'Afrique euh l'Afrique de
l'Ouest il va falloir considérer que
effectivement les politiques de
développement doivent être des
politiques qui doivent être mises en
œuvre mais il faut être conscient de ce
que les politiques de développement sont
des politiques lorsqu'elles sont bien
mené qui dans les premières années de
leur mise en œuvre créent de la
migration parce que précisément les
personnes ont un capital plus important
à la fois financier mais de savoir qui
leur permet de de bouger ce qui veut
dire que si on on veut sérieusement se
poser la question des politiques de
développement et de leur caractère
effectif il faut la sortir d'une
politique de mobilité tout à l'heure
quand je parlais de mobilité humaine ce
n'était pas par facilité de langage
parce que je considère fondamentalement
que le monde dans lequel nous rentrons
aujourd'hui n'est pas un monde de
migration ou d'immigration
d'installation mais c'est très
certainement aussi en monde de mobilité
et il va falloir réussir à organiser la
mobilité de ces personnes et la facilité
en réalité dernier élément là je laisse
la parole à au professeur Dumont euh les
politiques de développement c'est une
chose très
intéressante mais quand bien même les
chiffres qui ont été annoncés il y a
quelques quelques minutes de 30
milliards d'euros ces chiffreslà sont
quand même très en de ça de la capacé de
de des envois de fonds les envois de
fonds privés représentent 450 milliards
de dollars par an cette somme-là est
considérable et c'est peut-être aussi
sur ces envois de fonds là qu'il faut
essayer de travailler essayer de faire
en sorte qu'on puisse les mobiliser de
manière positive pas simplement pour des
individualités mais peut-être pour des
communautés je vous remercie
merci cette qualité de réponse monsieur
le professeur vous avez un déf merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
donc je crois qu'il faut que je réponde
d'abord à la première question
c'est-à-dire pourquoi Schengen n'a pas
été appliqué je ne rappellerai pas les
règles la raison chacun la connaît ici
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait la seule
stratégie de l'Union européenne ces 15
dernières années a été de s'élargir pour
s'élargir sans tenir compte de la
capacité des pays à respecter les règles
de l'Union européenne en effet je vous
rappelle que le principe fondamental de
l'Union européenne c'est que de ne doit
entrer dans une politique de l'Union
européenne qu'un pays qui a la une
machine administrative permettant d'en
appliquer les règles or ce principe
fondamental n'a pas été justement
respecté et donc il en est résulté un
élargissement de l'Union européenne et
notamment de l'espace Schengen à des
pays qui ne sont pas en situation pas
seulement administrative mais
géographique de respecter le code
frontière Schengen et donc c'est d'où la
conséquence que nous avons
aujourd'hui dans cette situation et qui
met en cause Schengen et ça rejoint la
question sur le col du brainire parce
que je crois qu'il faut surtout pas se
voiler la face hein Schengen aujourd'hui
est malheureusement plus près de la
tombe que de la Renaissance alors je
pense qu'il faudrait mieux faire un
diagnostic précis et considérer qu'il
est près de la tombe si on veut arriver
à ce que ce soit un phénix le deuxième
point qui a été évoqué c'est
effectivement le fait que à travers ces
migrations de disons on va dire de ces
18 dernier mois nous n'avons pas eu que
des personnes qui venaient de
Mésopotamie alors effectivement dans la
mesure où comme l'a dit le directeur de
Frontex la Turquie s'est transformée en
autoroute am migrant et bien
automatiquement se sont engouffré sur
cette autoroute des personnes qui
venaient d'autres régions et qui
cherchaient leur salut cela c'est toute
l'histoire des migrations de toutes ces
décennies notamment puisque monsieur le
sénateur je corrigerai si vous le
permettez juste un point c'est-à-dire
les premiers morts en fait date du
détroit de Gibraltar et des Canaris hein
et l'enrayement ce qui est très
intéressant c'est comment a été enrayé
les flux migratoires entre le Sénégal et
les Canaris ils ont été enrayés d'abord
par des moyens effectivement militaires
mais aussi par un travail au Sénégal et
notamment il y a eu un travail
considérable des mères sénégalaises qui
n'en pouvait plus de voir certains de
leurs adolescents se noyer au large du
Sénégal et de la Mauritanie et qui donc
ont mené un combat pour empêcher leurs
jeunes de continuer à partir sur des
bateaux donc effectivement nous avons là
une une situation qui est plus générale
dont je n'ai pas eu le temps de parler
tout à l'heure alors face à cette
situation quelle solution
imaginer alors je dis pas qu'il y a de
solution parfaite mais il est pas
inintéressant de se tourner dans une
autre région du monde pour voir ce qui
est pratiqué lorsque nous avons des
vagues migratoires significative et
maritime alors regardons les accords qui
existent entre les États-Unis et Cuba
depuis
1994 donc qui fonctionne depuis 22 ans
ce sont des accords qui fonctionnent sur
le principe piedse pied
mouillés c'est-à-dire que le cubain qui
quitte sur une une barque quelconque
Cuba pour essayer de rejoindre la
Floride s'il parvient jusqu'à une plage
de Floride il a le pied sec c'est il
pose le pied sur la plage et là les
États-Unis disent ah il a pénétré sur
mon territoire je le
garde si ce sont des gardes frontières
qui en mer interceptent la personne et
bien elle le ramène gentiment à Cuba
voilà bon voilà il faut savoir le genre
de chose qui est fait alors évidemment
quand vous élargissez la question les
causes migratoires du 20e siècle du 21e
siècle seront les mêmes que celles qui
ont existé tout au cours de l'histoire
de l'humanité donc concernant l'Afrique
chacun connaît parfaitement la situation
l'Afrique a tous les moyens de son
développement elle a un potentiel
agricole industriel commercial et je
dirais même que son potentiel s'améliore
parce que l'augmentation de la densité
de la population rentabilise un certain
nombre d'activités économiques qui
lesétait moins quand la densité était
beaucoup plus faible en Afrique la
question elle est celle de la
gouvernance c'est-à-dire soit
effectivement les pays africains sont
bien gouvernés et auquel cas les gens
n'ont pas envie de partir le meilleur
exemple a été donné par la Côte d'Ivoire
pendant 40 ans enfin en gros du temps d'
fouette boini aucun ivoirien n'avait
envie de quitter la Côte d'Ivoire la
situation s'amélioréit on était content
chez soi on on savait qu'elle allait
continuer de s'améliorer on a commencé à
voir une émigration à partir de la Côte
d'Ivoire que lors du conflit civil en
Côte d'Ivoire au milieu des années
2000 donc ce qui est vrai pour la Côte
d'Ivoire est vrai pour l'ensemble euh
des pays d'Afrique et pose
nécessairement effectivement la question
de la politique du développement alors
je suis gêné d'en parler notamment
devant Jean-Marie bequel mais il faut
quand même préciser que nos politiques
française en matière de développement
ont quand même consisté assez largement
à favoriser le
multilatérisme par rapport au
bilatéralisme et ça c'est un vrai
problème c'est-à-dire la France ne sa
n'a plus les les moyens d'agir sur les
fonds qui sont donnés à des fonds
multilatéraux et le l'échec j'iris de
notre aide au développement
puisque je crois que c'est Hubert Falco
qui a cité l'Algérie c'est que quel est
le pays au monde qui a reçu le plus
d'aide au développement depuis un
demi-sècle c'est l'Algérie c'est
l'Algérie je vous rappelle en effet que
nous surpayons pendant des années nous
avons surpayé le pétrole algérien pour
favoriser le développement de
l'Algérie donc vous voyez que je crois
que il y a effectivement une décision
stratégique à prendre par par la France
qui effectivement de
constater que cette priorité que que
l'on a donné au multi arisme dans l'aide
au développement il faut certainement
revenir dessus et nous voyons bien
d'ailleurs que l'aide au développement
mise en œuvre au Royaume-Uni par le
Royaume-Uni qui a moins donné au
multilitarisme et beaucoup plus efficace
alors concernant aussi la question de
Madame prole Dumont sur l'avenir de
l'Union européenne j'étéis très surpris
ces derniers jours par le journal Le
Monde au sujet de la remise du prix
charleman au pape François
parce que dans la version papier bon il
y avait un éditorial gentillaet sur
cette question mais dans la version
numérique du monde qui n'a pas été
repris dans la version papier il a été
écrit
déboussolé les dirigeants européens s'en
remettent au pape François c'était
extraordinaire si vous voulez parce
qu'en fait ce mot définissait bien la
situation actuelle et qui est
explicative aussi euh du rédissement des
opinions dont vous avez parlé parce que
si les opinions se rédisent c'est parce
qu'elles ont l'impression que leurs
dirigeants ne maîtrisent plus rien et
qu'elles ne savent plus où les
dirigeants les mènent donc moi-même j'ai
rédigé un papier pour montrer que
malheureusement l'Union européenne est
en train de mettre en parenthèse un
certain nombre de ses valeurs valeurs de
liberté de démocratie et de subsidiarité
et donc il faut absolument que l'Union
européenne respecte d'abord elle-même
ses valeurs dans dans les décisions
qu'elle prend et dans la façon de les
mettre en œuvre si elle vaut perdurer
c'était le début vous Rappelz de mon
introduction enfin je terminerai si vous
me permettez monsieur le Président juste
sur un point absolument essentiel dans
la compréhension des
migrations en réalité les populations
dans leur très grande majorité veulent
vivre et travailler au pays pourquoi par
exemple y a-t-il encore
autant de Syriens en Jordanie au Liban
et en Turquie parce que 44 % d'entre
eux reviennent régulièrement en Syrie
pour aller voir de la famille qui est
restée pour voir où en est l'état de
sesbiens et cetera donc ce qu'il
souhaiteraiit réellement c'est retourner
en Syrie c'est-à-dire que les choses
s'apaisent donc il ne faut pas dirais en
encourager les départs par contre il
faut aider les pays dans le pays et
chacun sait bien ici qu'entre nous d'un
point de vue purement financier ça coûte
beaucoup moins cher d'aider un Syrien en
Syrie que d'intégrer un Syrien en
France et et donc ça c'est un point
absolument essentiel et donc qu'il faut
garder à l'esprit et donc cela suppose
en particulier effectivement d'aider les
rien chez eux alors que nous avons mis
en place un certain nombre de décisions
politiques aujourd'hui qui empêchent de
le
faire c'est formidable comme analyse
alors les
responsabilités quand je vois le nombre
de candidats à la présidence de la
République je me dis que les
responsabilités ils sont conscients ça
va être lourd sur les épaules quand même
parce que ne serait-ce que ce paradoxe
européen qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire parce que les deux choses
sont vraies c'est que c'est vrai que
plus on fait de multilatéral Mo on fait
de binational c'estàd que notre mais en
même temps on veut que l'Europe agisse
plus donc on est toujours face à un
paradoxe comment comment on gère ça
parce que c'est c'est vrai qu'on a
délégué beaucoup de nos interventions
donc on perd de notre influence on perd
de notre action de notre opérationnalité
mais en même temps il nous faut
construire parce que le sujet est aussi
européen et donc on veut construire des
outils donc on est quand même toujours
en permanence etcartelé sur toutes ces
question mais là je je crois ce qui est
quand même très important pour nous et
ce que vous nous dites en remettant tout
ce sujet dans l'histoire c'est qu'au
fond tout ce qui se passe là est un
signe de ce qui va se passer dans dans
l'avenir et que nous sommes au début
d'une nouvelle aventure et qu'on n'est
pas simplement en train de d'analyser un
un accord entre la Turquie et et
l'Europe sur un point précis c'est qu'on
a d'autres sujets qui vont faire en
sorte que ce cette question là c'est
vraiment une question question majeure
de notre propre destin quoi donc en tout
cas merci et de niveau de de vos
analyses et et merci de la qualité de de
vos réponses c'était passionnant pour
nous tous et on a tous ici la la
conscience de de ce sujet qui est de
première importance merci à vous tous
voilà vous avez pu suivre cette table
ronde consacrée à la question migratoire
un thème qui a rythmé l'actualité cette
année avec la manière dont l'Europe a
géré cette crise vous pouvez revoir bien
sûr ce programme sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr vos rendez-vous avec
public
sat le Tour de France est un événement
sans égal quand il célèbre la
Fraternelle communion des hommes quand
il offre aux supporters l'opportunité de
toucher l'étof des héros et de pousser
les champions dans la
pente on n pas une connaissance homogène
des phénomènes et de la